[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar oncotopicsdiscovery
deep learning as a standard analysis
method for digital pathology images
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by vizio farm to learn more visit
viziofarm.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
fabian schneider r d and product
management at physio farm
and dr david mason senior technical
sales specialist at vizio farm
dr schneider dr mason you may now begin
your presentation
welcome to this physiopharm presentation
introducing oncotopics discovery
a quick disclaimer all products
mentioned in this presentation offer
research use only
vizio farm does have a portfolio of
clinically appropriate products if
you're interested in learning more
please use the email address on the
screen now
within the field of digital pathology
and digital image analysis
there are many common questions that
people have
when approached with complex problems
here are some of them
there are so many packages available so
many software and so many approaches
that many people are confused about
which one is best or which one is
appropriate for their particular system
or model
we also hear a lot of people who are
domain experts in their biological area
unsure how to convert their biological
knowledge into analysis
lastly many people who approach an image
analysis workflow find that there's too
much time spent in development training
or modifying existing workflows
this combined with many other questions
leads us to the point that there's a
need for powerful tools but that are
easy to use and accessible to everybody
hopefully during the course of this
short talk we will answer some of these
questions and demonstrate how vizio
farms approach can be used to solve
these and many other problems
i'd like to start by addressing this
first point
visio farm has been in this digital
pathology and digital image analysis
space for over 20 years
during this time we've seen many
different
approaches
and we are of the opinion that deep
learning has now got to a point where
there is the optimal approach for the
vast majority of questions within the
digital pathology space
complex problems require advanced tools
and this is where deep learning shines
you can see in this example
this is a tumor detection problem in
breast cancer
you can identify tumor areas by their
darker hematoxylin or darker blue
staining such as the area identified
here
and you'll notice that the contrast
between these structures and stromal
structures
are very low
it's a really subtle difference in
nuclear shape
and also morphology
this is also a particularly difficult
problem because as you can see
in this ihc image
some of the cells are positive for dab
this brown stain and some are negative
and in this case we can of course see a
large variance of the number of positive
cells and their morphology when we look
at different sections
deep learning allows you to segment
these complex tissues without the need
for secondary or complex stains
often using simple stains such as h e or
ihcdab
it handles subtle or low contrast
structures very well
and lastly possibly the most important
point is that deep learning allows you
to build robust approaches that can
handle stain and tissue variants such as
the ones that are commonly seen with
different section thicknesses different
staining modalities or different
approaches
these are key points as to why we feel
deep learning is the best approach in
the vast majority of biological
questions
but more than that what this enables
is to allow the software to take over
and replace laborious manual tasks such
as identifying areas of interest or
excluding artifacts with end-to-end
automation
now you don't have to take our word for
it
a simple search of the literature of
papers published in peer-reviewed
journals
shows that the field is definitely
moving towards adoption of deep learning
pathology and we believe will continue
to do so as these technologies are made
more available to more people
so what sort of problems can deep
learning solve in the digital pathology
space
the answer is almost everything that
we've come across
from simple things such as nuclear
detection in bright field and
fluorescent images
tissue segmentation to identify areas of
necrosis or metastasis
and even outside of oncology
into toxicological pathology looking at
things like kidney structure glomerular
detection
cell invasion and cell classification
deep learning has almost infinite scope
as to the sorts of projects stains and
approaches that it can help with
having explained what deep learning can
do
what i'd like to point out is that with
visiofarm's release of the new
oncotopics discovery platform we have
decided to take this technology and give
it to everyone who accesses vizier farm
software
we call this deep learning for everyone
as we truly believe that this
groundbreaking technology of deep
learning
can be used to solve a vast range of
problems
this means that anyone engaging with
visiofarm will then have access to deep
learning tools in the standard package
this means using these powerful tools
across any modality
imaging mass cytometry fluorescence or
bright field imaging for example
and all of the major file formats
of course the standard package comes
with fully customizable outputs so you
can create the metrics that you desire
it's accessible with no coding or
scripting required
and it also has extensible functionality
and what i mean by that is that for
instance if you use tissue microarrays
you can use our tissue arraying tool to
easily de-array and manage tma cores for
individual analysis
likewise if your work involves high or
ultraplex data as we often see in
fluorescent imaging or imaging mass
cytometry you can use our specialized
multiplex phenotyping and data
exploration tools
to help your studies using these data
types
if you ever do serial sections or serial
staining approaches
regardless of the modality bright field
fluorescence or a combination of both
we have tissue align tools that within
the software register these serially
sectioned or serially stained images
these three packages are fully
integrated with the visiofarm software
so you can use them in combination with
our deep learning tools that come as
standard
we also have a range of extended
authoring tools that let users optimize
deep learning settings and pick from a
wider range of classifiers
i'd like to now talk about how we can
take these deep learning tools and use
them to actually solve problems in a
method that we call see it train it find
it
this really addresses the problem of
taking your biological knowledge and
converting it into analysis
we've taken these tools that are highly
powerful and basically made them easy to
use without any computational knowledge
whatsoever
in the first step the user simply looks
at their images
and identifies different areas that
they're interested in
segmenting in this case you can see
tumor and stroma highlighted
the second step is simply to provide
annotations
giving examples of tumor areas here in
red and stromal areas here in green
with a push of a button the user can
then train the software to show what
these different areas look like across
single or multiple images
once this is done we can move on to step
three which is find it
taking a whole slide image and then
simply running the app that has been
produced
then provides you with any number of
results in both regions or numbers that
you'd like
see it train it find us
the last thing i'd like to mention is
the pre-trained knowledge that comes
with oncotopics discovery
as we've mentioned it's very easy for
users to develop their own apps with the
see it train it find it approach
but in many cases there's even a quicker
way to get to your answers
visio farm can be used across
any range of tissues stains and
modalities
and oncotopics discovery deep learning
is versatile and robust
so what this means is that not only can
solutions be used
to take into account
the variability seen across different
images
it can also handle different modalities
such as fluorescence
imaging mass cytometry and brightfield
and this pre-trained knowledge is
available to end users with a push
button simplicity
a great example of this is with our
nuclear detection apps
available to users of visiofarm that can
just be plugged straight into your own
data
and the majority of cases will work off
the shelf
this significantly speeds up development
time and allows you to
get to your results much faster than
training these yourself
i'd like to now give a quick example
demonstration of some of the pre-trained
knowledge and how it looks in the vizio
farm software
here we can see a whole face breast
cancer section
stained with ihc dab for ki 67 a
proliferation marker
if we zoom into the image we can see
different areas of interest and we have
some tumor areas and some stroma areas
as introduced earlier in the talk
visio farm runs well across whole slide
images but can also be used on regions
of interest within images
it's worth noting that regions of
interest can be adapted
erased
or added
to identify specific regions of interest
here by selecting a region and then
simply hitting run
from the ribbon
we can start to use this pre-trained
knowledge to identify
tumor areas within this region
you'll notice that in real time here the
tumor areas are identified and outlined
in this blue dashed region of interest
we also have access to customized
metrics such as the tumor area in
millimeter squared
one of the really powerful things about
this pre-trained knowledge is that you
can actually daisy chain together
multiple apps here not only to detect
tumor but for instance to do a cell
detection and classification
which can be specified to be within
tumor regions within stromal regions
or both
this is particularly useful if you've
done tissue segmentation for instance to
exclude areas of artifacts
these then are no longer analyzed as
part of your whole sequence saving you
time and providing an end-to-end
analysis solution
as you can see the cells are detected
classified and then recorded
each of these cells is counted as either
negative in blue or positive in red the
numbers are reported in the results
table
and also a custom metric the
proliferation index is calculated this
is simply the percentage of positive
cells
here the overlays opacity can be changed
and customized to see the underlying
data
and confirm that these are in fact
identifying and classifying cells
correctly
this is a great example of pre-trained
knowledge in action
using off-the-shelf apps to do tumor
detection and cell detection
i'd like to highlight another example of
where pre-trained knowledge can be used
and also the power of deep learning
approaches
here if we look at
kidney images
where the aim of the project is to
identify glomeruli
what we can see is that in all of these
cases the same app has been run
to detect glomeruli regardless of their
underlying staining
on the left is cd68
in the middle is collagen
and on the right is nephron
this highlights the power of deep
learning where you can identify
the same structures in three different
staining regimes that are drastically
different
simply by seeing it training it and
finding it
users can create their own powerful deep
learning apps to solve these sorts of
problems
i'd like to thank you for your attention
for this presentation of oncotopic's
discovery
our approach of deep learning for
everyone
see it train it find it
and the demonstration of pre-trained
knowledge
if you have any questions after this
presentation
you can use the email address shown on
this slide
thank you dr schneider dr mason for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
how is the vizio farm platform installed
workstation server cloud and ce etc
thank you very much marie for the
question um
i would like to hand this to david as he
is one of our
senior technical sales specialist to
answer that in detail okay
hi thank you for the question um vizio
farm can actually be installed in any
number of these environments so
oftentimes people will match the
underlying hardware to their required
turnaround time for instance if you
wanted to run a 1000 slide study
very quickly in half an hour or an hour
for instance then we can certainly
advise on how you would want to install
into a gpu cluster for instance it's
worth pointing out also that if you are
installing on physical workstations or
workstations in the cloud that we also
have options for parallelizing
processing
so for instance you can utilize as many
computers as you have to split up the
processing jobs and the training jobs
and
make it a much more efficient processing
thank you
next question
do i have any control of the deep
learning settings
yes you have so in the in the standard
version you don't
then you can just
add your annotations and labels as
needed for the training of the deep
learning
but with the
extension of your platform with the
extended author you also have a module
to tweak
the parameters of the networks
thank you
our next question is
is an h e train algorithm also good for
an ihc image
yes this is a good question and it
definitely depends on which
um
part of the agent you have trained on so
if this would be for example
a nuclear
with
the um
hdx sustaining detection then you are
able to transfer that but our platform
comes with pre-trained uh nuclear
detection networks as indicated by
david's talk maybe do you want to add
something to this
yeah i think i would just add that this
is one of the real benefits of deep
learning is that the output will highly
depend on the input so for instance if
as with the kidney case that i showed in
the talk you had an h e image and an ihc
image you can include training data from
both of those different stains
and that way it allows the app to
understand
what the thing you're looking for is
even if the staining regime changes it's
incredibly powerful in that regard and
as
fabian mentioned the one example that we
have that ships with every vizio farm
install is the cell detection that works
out of the box across h e and ihc
great thank you
um
next question
does see it train it find it work in
fluorescent data what is the maximum
number of input channels i can use
that's a great question
david
yeah so actually there's no practical
limit of the number of input channels
and something not mentioned or mentioned
briefly in the talk is that visio farm
is actually acquisition agnostic so we
frequently work with both ihc data
with fluorescent data in the low plex
six to seven channels
with fluorescent data in the
intermediate high and ultraplex as well
as imaging mass cytometry
so the some of the biggest data sets
we've seen are actually 70 or 80
channels or even more but there's
actually no limit on the input data
you also have the choice as to which
channels are included in the see it
train it find it approach with deep
learning
yes and just to add on that um
with our platform you also get hands on
all the native file format reading like
we are the only platform natively
reading uh the fluidim mcd file formats
with all metadata we are
reading the qp tiffs from akoya and can
stitch all of these images together
automatically upon import
we read
nanostring images we read 10x genomics
images we can read also
annotations from ai fourier we can read
past core image file formats etc
so with with this platform you have a
great
abundance of image file formats that you
can easily use
great thank you
our next question is
how can end-to-end analysis be performed
if there are bubbles or tissue folds in
the images
that's yeah this is a great question and
i'm happy to take this one um
obviously what we're trying to do with
deep learning is enable people to do end
to end as the questioner asked and
really by removing the need to manually
exclude these artifactual areas it gives
you an incredible power to be able to
batch process large amounts of data
and the answer is actually in the see it
train it find it approach because if you
have for instance a tissue section and
you'd like to exclude all of the tissue
folds
dust staining artifacts you can simply
highlight these areas in exactly the
same way that we highlighted the
different areas in the tumor example
and then choose which areas of the
tissue excluding the artifacts you would
like to go on and process
so it really gives you a very powerful
approach to be able to end to end
analyze
even quite complex images
yes and i think what we need to add to
this is
if you can
see it and label it then you can create
your networks to perform your qc
of all your images for exclusional
great thank you
next question
if i want to perform my own analysis can
i access the underlying data
um
i don't know what
to to fully i don't fully understand
that question david you
yeah i mean i can take a stab in this
case oftentimes what we hear people
wanting to do is you know if you have a
particular workflow and you have a
favorite statistical approach downstream
of your analysis
then you may want to take that and then
run your data through an r script or a
custom visualization for instance
and at vizio farm we're not in the
business of locking people into the
platform so you can always access both
the data the numerical outputs from your
analysis but also the masks as well so
any of the regions of interest that
you've seen in the talk today
can also be exported either as tiffs or
as xml if you prefer structured data so
if that's what the questioner was asking
then you can be assured that you can
always export your results and export
your overlays and then customize how you
use them downstream
yeah
maybe another
take on how you can how i understood the
question as well is
yes all the pre-trained
networks you can adjust to your own
needs and can train further on it if it
doesn't perform on your
tissue type for example
thank you
next question
how do you do qc on this
accuracy and precision of the analysis
that's a good question and i think
what you have to do is uh
best explained by david
yeah sure thing and you know qc is an
absolutely critical part of any image
analysis development
and in this case what we come across is
what are you comparing to so visio farm
is a very easy to use interface if you
want to bring a pathologist in and just
by eye look at the outputs and confirm
whether or not they fit what the biology
is suggesting to the biological expert
you can do that of course in some cases
you won't have direct access to the
pathologist so for instance you would
have a ground truth set of data or a
ground truth set of masks these can be
easily imported into the vizio farm
platform and you can actually calculate
inline
sensitivity and specificity scores
if you wanted to look at overlap of
course there are many metrics you can
calculate such as the dice index or the
the jacquard index and this tells you
how well your app is performing compared
to your ground truth
of course one of the biggest
restrictions is where do you get that
ground truth from and we've run into
something called the the gold standard
paradox of course is that you're always
comparing to something else
one other thing to add is when you are
doing qc with visio farm when you run an
app you can always lock it down and
suggest that you don't want any more
changes to the way that this deep
learning app works
or if you're during development you can
review the results and then use a form
of transfer learning where you simply
correct the outputs and then hit
continue training and continue to refine
your deep learning application
so it's really flexible about how you
approach it but we give you the tools
and the platform to be able to qc and to
be able to calculate these sensitivity
scores
thank you
we have time for one more question does
the software score the biopsy tissues
such as the gleason scoring in case of
prostate cancer
yes so that's a great question so
this is already going into the
translational more clinical side and the
oncotopics discovery is our research
platform
and we also have an oncotopics clinical
platform in which we have ivdr or
certified um
apps like for ks67 and breast tissue or
her2
and these are now
further developed in the future and what
you can always do and this is the beauty
of the system is that you can
create any outputs for your um for your
networks that you would like to have
so you have a vast majority of
post-processing steps and then can
create a vast
amount of outputs like
all the intensities
positionings and then give
different cutoffs of your intensities a
different score
yeah and i would just add to that also
that in many cases if people are taking
the first steps into digital pathology
and digital image analysis we can
replicate many of the scoring techniques
that people are used to doing at a
microscope so for instance selecting 10
high power fields and then scoring
within those or randomly assigning
regions to to analyze and coming up with
more qualitative scores that match how
the pathologist may be assessing broadly
some of the tissues so flexibility is
really the key in how we approach
outputs
thank you again uh what we have one more
question we have time for one more
question does the software provide
contrast enhancement for visualizing the
tissues
so there's a full suite of visualization
options
in visio farm so you can always control
for instance with multiplex data which
channels are represented which channels
are shown in which combinations change
their individual colors but also alter
the brightness and contrast and some
gamma settings either broadly for the
whole tissue or per channel so on a
specific case
this is really critical in some cases if
we do
multiplex where some of the stains are
very dim and some of them are very
bright obviously you would need to do a
per channel
adjustment so that you can visualize the
structures that you're trying to train
and
analyze
thank you
just one more question can it detect
mitotic figures
um yes so
if you can train it on the mitotic
figures then you can definitely detect
metallic figures the question is you can
also do the transfer learning like if
you have a histone a phosphoric stone h3
stain
and you can
um
align the slide with an agent e then you
have exact uh presence of where you have
your
mitotic cells on the uh on one cell on
the on slide one compared to slide two
and you can transfer that and pre
perform the algorithms for example
um the the deep learning training of
with this information from the phosphory
stone h3 you can also do this with
sequential staining like
you first stain for the agent e wash it
and then do the take a picture and then
you do the phosphorus tone h3
i would also add to that that if you're
interested in abnormal mitoses we can
also just using the same see it train it
find this approach in a simple h e image
for instance
identifying not only cells that are
non-mitotically active and mitotically
active but identify various stages or
abnormalities for instance cells
dividing incorrectly or getting stalled
halfway so
the the trick is to try to provide
flexibility in a way that allows you to
answer your biological questions
and it's important that you can annotate
all of these different stages so that
you have enough examples for the for the
network to learn it
well thank you again dr schneider dr
mason for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor vizio
farm for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you